turning to Congress Senate Republican
leaders say they will release a draft
tomorrow of their health care bill
senators from both parties have
complained about being cut out of the
process White House spokesman Sean
Spicer says President Trump wants the
health care bill to have heart and to
cortices on Capitol Hill with the
political fight Nancy good morning good
morning Republican leaders argue that
lots of bills get hashed out behind
closed doors and that everything will be
revealed tomorrow but even some
Republican senators are starting to say
that this level of secrecy is unusual
and unhelpful I haven't seen the bill
Utah Senator Mike Lee took to Facebook
Tuesday to express his frustration
he's one of 13 Senate Republicans
supposedly writing the health care bill
but he said the process has been taken
over by GOP leaders I'm told that it
exists I just haven't been able to see
it yet and as far as I know the
overwhelming majority of my colleagues
haven't been able to see it either do
not let this go by without your voice
three Democrats tried to make a point by
live-streaming a visit to the
Congressional Budget Office where they
failed to get a copy of the GOP plan
Republicans are shutting us and the
American public out of this process
Republican leaders are trying to craft a
bill that marks a clean break with
Obamacare but does not resemble the
House GOP bill which President Trump
described as mean how will your bill
have more heart as the president puts it
than the House version it'll be
different and take a different approach
based upon these endless discussions
we've had with the only people
interested in changing the law which is
Republican senators well you say that
Democrats aren't interested but they're
not invited into Europe they wouldn't
they've made it clear earlier they were
not interested in participating in this
they have no interest in it whatsoever
Democratic leader Chuck Schumer disputed
that never sought out negotiations never
sought our opinions just decided to do
this in the dark of night even
Republicans are now making light of the
elusive bill maybe
the Russians have been able to hack in
and got most of Everett I haven't we are
told that the bill will mean fewer
changes for people with pre-existing
conditions and that it will be more
generous than the House bill when it
comes to tax credits and Medicaid but
Jeff we won't know how much more
generous until we get a look at that
draft tomorrow all right Nancy thank you
very much